this is serious business that were
engaged in and it is on one level among
ourselves it is communication and
sharing an opening and building
consensus but when we turn away from our
family and out toward the uncompromised
then it becomes propaganda it becomes a
struggle for the hearts and minds of
people everywhere and I think most
people are with us it's simply that they
haven't had that explained to them in
such a way that they were able to
realize that in other words we're not
out to convert anybody to anything we're
out to help people discover that they
agreed with this point of view all along
it has to be so because after all we
stand for something fairly simple and
unambiguous life survival continuity
caring relationship feeling joy who's
going to vote against this if it's
properly explained to them so I view
these things as consciousness-raising
sessions in the old style and hope that
you will see it as more than even
privately inspiring entertainment but
that you will go out and get these
points of view too people get these
attitudes out not unto the greater glory
of Terence Mckenna or Nicole Maxwell or
the Ojai Foundation but because this
needs to be said it needs to be
empowered the first step towards solving
any problem is an awareness that the
problem exists now we're all very tired
of that
as we've been suffering and agonizing
over the problem of a dying or some of
us for years
nevertheless the astonishing news is
some folks haven't heard or have only
heard recently and it's very important
not to panic them or alarm them but to
inspire them and motivate them and bring
them into the project of reclaiming the
earth I mean this is our legacy this is
our birthright it is the legacy and
birthright of our unborn children and
you know there isn't even there maybe
there is that I don't know it it rich as
Greek is there isn't a word for being so
perverse that you devour your own
children the money ins the women
possessed of Dian Isaac frenzy what was
always put against them was that they
devoured their own children this is a
propaganda image
that to be smeared with this is to be
tainted very deeply well it is literally
true that we are guilty of a crime which
the ancients could barely conceive
we are looting the planet for our
pleasure
our condominiums speedboats and
electronic gadgetry is literally part of
the legacy of our children what kind of
people comprise the larger society in
which we are embedded that they would do
a thing like that it's a crime beyond
war war
you simply slaughter all the fools who
volunteer for it and all the fools who
stand around and watch but to destroy
the potential of a future for our
children is a crime that boggles the
mind and this is the final stage of the
Dominator metaphor when I picked up the
New York Times a year ago and read that
the United States State Department was
advocating the spraying of aerial
herbicides over the waii chaga Basin to
eradicate coca I to me it felt like a
turning point comparable to the
assassination of John Kennedy or Pearl
Harbor it was so clear
perverse so clearly directed against
itself the contradictions become so
odious that at a certain point people of
moral dignity feel they have no option
left except to somehow throw themselves
on the cogs of the machinery to try and
halt it from carrying out the program of
moloch the program of self development
that we have set in motion now if ever
there was a moment to talk to your
neighbors clarify your own thinking
support organizations that are trying to
make a difference now is the time and we
can make a difference and I know you
have heard that and it's a cliche and
there's a tendency not to believe it
I've been here and we only botanical
dimensions was fairly narrowly focused
until a couple of years ago on saving
shamanic Allison engines then really
through Kats process the need was felt
to encompass this whole problem of
destruction of the warm tropics so I
began writing letters to the UN and the
IMF and the World Bank and all of these
people expecting to find a vast
well-funded edifice of her you know
typing pools and computer networks and
people doing something I discovered that
very little is going on we have advanced
long way down this path on yak alone
there is not somewhere vast
organizations toiling to contact every
Brazilian politician and put the twist
on him toiling to contact every American
corporation that is contributing to this
atrocity and threatening them with stock
sell-offs boycotts and whatever all the
obvious things that you may think are
being done you may then dismiss by
saying well I'm sure I shouldn't do that
surely somewhere a staff of 50 is
working on that problem well when you
look into it you discover it is not
happening if any one of you has a
moderate or great wealth and have
decided not to pitch in with saving the
rainforest because you think a lot of
people are working in that field already
forget it the number of people waving
their arms about it is legion the number
of people who are actually attempting to
halt it is countable on the fingers of
two hands you know the world can be
saved it's simply a matter of diverting
I would say 5% of GNP to do it well only
a terminally psychopathic person would
refuse to divert 5 percent of their
energy flow toward their own salvation
if we can't get our act together to do
that I think the calm and cool judgement
of Gaia Almighty is who needed such
clowns I'll hang out with the octopi the
dolphins the butterflies and the termite
nests I don't need this headache you
know I don't need acid rain I don't need
strontium in the environment
I don't need extraction of petroleum
products and tons of junk in orbit
in order to foster what Shakespeare
there hasn't been a Shakespeare for 500
years these clowns aren't producing
anything h-bombs don't make it in the
Gaian scale of values so the point here
is tremendously perverse misdirection of
resources a tremendous patience with
institutions that have proven that they
are either ineffective or actually the
enemy
Oh